hello and welcome thank you for joining
us for an election special live QA today
we're going to be analyzing the result
of Britain's general election the
Conservative Party has won 364 seats a
majority of at least 78 one constituency
is still to declare but it marks the big
the party's biggest electoral victory
since the days of Margaret Thatcher so
what will five more years of Prime
Minister Boris Johnson's Tory Party rule
mean for Britain and the rest of the
world I'm Sarah Collinson a video
journalist here at The Economist in
London I'm joined by Zanny Minton
Beddoes our editor-in-chief and Adrian
Wooldridge our political editor we'll be
answering your questions this morning
good morning zani Adrian it's great to
have you both here it's been a busy
night for many here as the results have
come in zani what did the night look
like for you well it was as you said a
pretty cataclysmic night I guess it
really got going at 10 p.m. which is
when the exit polls came out and they
showed that there was likely to be a
much bigger conservative majority than
anybody expected there was a visible
kind of you know in the room of us
watching but then everybody got to work
we produced half a dozen new articles
overnight and you cover leader a new
cover image which you'll see Boris
Johnson with a with the Churchillian V
for victory a new lots of analysis
Adrian our budget columnist produced an
excellent new budget where he told us
about what was going to happen to the
Labour Party after it's rather
cataclysmic defeat and I think we were
trying to make sense of just what this
very dramatic realignment in British
politics meant and we should not
underestimate the scale of this
realignment this is an extraordinary
majority it is on a scale with Margaret
Thatcher it is on a scale you know
possibly even with Clement Attlee it's a
huge huge shift and the big question now
is what does this shift mean for British
politics and can it last you can read
our new leader and all of our new
coverage by following the links in the
description of this film and Adrian what
were the key moments of the night the
key moments for the night was
essentially when the red wall of Labor
seats began to collapse and that was the
story of the night really was was the
Tory party winning in seats where it has
never won before which have always been
labor seats places like great Grimm's
places like Blythe Valley people you
know quite often mining communities
steel communities people who'd been
devastated in fact by the last Tory
Revolution we're turning to the Tory
party and I think there were the two
extraordinary things going on what is
the lesson for this country and one of
them is that the Tory party is an
extraordinary political organism it is
the oldest political party in the world
but in the in the sense of being
continuously either in power or the
major contender for power it has
reinvented itself over and over again it
reinvented itself with the rise of
democracy with the rise with the rise of
industrialism it was an aristocratic
party to start off with it reinvented
itself with protectionism turned itself
into a protectionist party in the early
20th century it reinvented itself after
the Second World War with the rise of
the welfare state it became a pretty
welfare state party it reinvented itself
with Thatcherism in the in the 1980s and
now it's reinventing itself again with
the rise of national populism around the
world and the second point I'd like to
make is this has extraordinary
implications for the United States that
it what it shows is that the sort of
blue-collar republicanism
that Trump is trying to forge has
resonance here and it suggests to the
United States that if they move to the
left with people like IOC in the way
that I think who tweeted or yesterday
morning yesterday or the day before me
which tweeted her support for
coordinates suggested that going down
that road the korbinite road is the road
to ruin
and so as Trump said you call Boris
Johnson Britain Trump a very odd phrase
but that's what you said it really is
important it's hard to overstate quite
water shift it is for these
constituencies in the north of the UK
these working-class constituencies who
for generations have never voted Tory
have now voted Tory for the first time I
think they've lent their votes to Boris
Johnson I don't think this is yet a
permanent realignment the real question
will be whether this this coalition
which we've we've called in our
editorial a coalition of blue collars
and red trousers red trousers being the
wealthier conservatives in the South the
traditional blue-collar working classes
they're now all voting for the hood the
doors for Boris actually and it's it was
striking during the night how many
people were just referring to Boris for
but it this is Boris Johnson's Viktor
he has enormous power over this party
now he's gone into Downing Street a man
who you know we have questioned his
fitness for office we've questioned
whether he could pull this kind of thing
off he's come in he's remade the party
and now it's kind of a question how how
durable that is and what can he do for
these two very very different
constituencies we know that the economic
needs of northern voters are very
different from the wealthier southern
ones and how does he pull off this
realignment as Adrian says the Tory
Party has historically been able to
reinvent itself and maybe this is the
beginning of one such historical and
durable realignment but it certainly got
off to a very powerful start yes
absolutely great well thanks for tuning
in and we'll we're taking questions from
some of you who sent them in already and
if you're watching this live you can
post your questions and we'll be keeping
an eye on them as we go and so to begin
taking a look at the initial market
reaction it seems a good place to start
zanny in one of our overnight pieces we
say that the market reaction to the exit
poll was as dramatic as the exit poll
itself the pound jumped against the
dollar rising by two percent in a matter
of minutes how can you explain this
surge and is it likely to last so the
markets did surge and they've surged
again this morning as the markets are
open and I think there are probably
three reasons the first is that there is
now clarity on brexit we are going to
leave the European Union on January 31st
quite what our eventual relationship
looks like is a longer-term thing and
there's going to be a lot more to do
there but in the short term we're
leaving their certainty that's good
markets like certainty secondly the
nationalization and expiration program
that was on the Corbyn agenda is often
it's interesting to see that some of the
companies that have done particularly
well are those that had a cloud of
possible nationalization hanging over
them and sadly I think there is an
expectation that Boris Johnson
government is going to spend more
they didn't say very much in their
manifesto but he is very very keen on
infrastructure spending he now needs to
come find a way to show that he is
delivering something for those new
voters in the north and I think there
will be more spending on particularly
for infrastructure again that is
something that markets reacting
favorably to because they're seeing the
economy propped up by more spending when
it lasts you know it depends what you
what time frame you mean I think there
is an interesting
trust here actually with the United
States because if you look at what's
happened to President Trump in the since
his election he has written an
incredibly strong US economy I'm not
sure that that will be the same here the
reason being that brexit will hurt the
UK economy there will be a cost to
brexit and depending on whether it's a
very hard brexit or not such a heart
breaks we'll see how big that cost is
but it is likely that this market
honeymoon may not last as long the world
economy is also not looking so great but
for the moment there is a huge sigh of
relief that it's not cool but in in
going anywhere near Downing Street and
there's thank Li in the markets a huge
sigh of relief that we've got some
clarity about where this country's going
one of the most important things has
happened it happened yesterday is that
Britain now has a government and we're a
country that didn't basically have a
government for the last three and a half
years we had a we had port resumes
trying to clean you on in Downing Street
unable to get anything through nobody to
get bricks it through in able to get any
effort legislation through and now we
have a government a large majority Boris
Johnson is the most powerful Prime
Minister since Tony Blair and most
powerful since since Margaret Thatcher
and the simple fact that we can do
things that the government is it has a
direction of purpose a capacity to
govern has really cleared up in my it
will get but I also yeah I also do think
that a lot of so many market people they
think that British asset prices have
been a bit undervalued they've been a
bit undervalued because of the cloud of
brexit and the uncertainty of brexit
also a bit undervalued because the plan
of call been in the uncertainty of
Corbin so I think we'll get some people
buying buying into British assets the
property market I think will will begin
to recover because the stagnation has
been a lot to do with uncertainty and
Adrian how has the rest of the world
reacted to the results I am afraid I
haven't really look to see what the rest
of the world is huge congratulations to
to Thoris Johnston and I think one of
the things that I was watching was the
eagerness with which the European
leaders who were actually meeting last
night were following this and I think
they're actually - there is a sigh of
relief at clarity in Britain it's not a
clarity it's not a direction that many
of them would have wanted but I think
there is a
a momentum that comes from having a
clear action there is no doubt what the
British people want now in European eyes
I think that's something that we're
leaving the EU that debate is now
finished that it was ended and that's
that's again another important moment it
was a clarifying evening and this was an
election that largely centered on brexit
the Conservatives ran on the pledge to
get brexit done a phrase that appeared
20 times in there 59 page manifesto and
how much do you think brexit influence
people's votes well I think that this
huge swathe of people in northern
England I travelled around the North
quite a lot during this election
campaign I was told over and over again
two things we want brexit done and
people think not because they thought it
was gonna be particularly good for the
economy because they voted for it and
they thought that the system had an
obligation to honor a democratic vote
that's what they were angry about and
secondly we don't like Jeremy Corbyn we
don't like Jeremy Cole we don't like his
politics we don't like the fact that
he's a sort of North London Islington
person who's very divorced from from
from our lives and we don't like the
sort of direction he's taking that part
of the anti-semitism comes up a lot the
extremism pelling around with the IRA
and Hamas and Hezbollah and the rest of
it so it was an election about Korbin
and election about break so that's just
about it I think it would be interesting
if the labour party draws the conclusion
that this was only about brexit I think
then they're in real trouble because it
was very much about Korbin and what
co-op endured for as well and you you
would hear out on the campaign trail
that brexit was was very much brought up
but corbin almost more so and there was
much Corbin was not a man who people in
the north of England the kinds of people
who had defected to the to the Tories
had any sense of identification with he
was there he was not that kind of person
at all and now we've had a question in
from one of my readers Rohan Shaheed has
asked once initiated will the ability to
stop brexit in any form cease if so
would this be better for economic
planning as it brings some degree of
certainty which you took yes I think
there is certainty now we're leaving I
think that's the 31st of January there
is no I think the one thing that Boris
Johnson would like the Parliament passed
before before to have brought before
Parliament is this withdrawal bill
before before Christmas so this is now
so lately Britain is leaving the opinion
and he's going to hold I think as a
sitting of Parliament on Saturday which
is something that almost never happens I
mean he's he's gonna hit the ground
running he's gonna have a huge sense of
urgency he has a mandate and he has the
energy to deliver what he's promised in
his terms and his mind so it's gonna be
a very energetic government and that's
if he looks a bit that the campaign
whatever you think of Boris's
performance it was certainly energetic
that's true and and so we can be
confident of mr. Johnson forcing his
renegotiated withdrawal agreement
through Parliament for Britain to
formally leave the EU by the current
deadline of January the 31st but what is
challenges after thereafter were on
brexit that is I think where the
challenge really starts because what
this withdrawal agreement does we leave
on January 31st we then enter a
transition period where effectively
everything stays the same except that we
are no longer formally members of
European Union we have to follow all
their rules we have to carry on paying
into that budget and that transition
agreement is slated to run until the end
of December 2020 in that pit time period
we are to negotiate a new permanent
trade deal with the European Union and
this is where that the challenge comes
and this is why perhaps I think there's
some more slightly more rockiness ahead
perhaps than Adrian does it is virtually
unheard of that a trade deal is
negotiated that quickly the the problem
third Boris Johnson is that if he wants
to diverge quite substantially from the
current rules of the European Union
which he has said he wants to do then
the Europeans will not want to grant
Britain as much access to their markets
as they currently have so there's a
trade-off there you can either have a
very simple permanent trade deal where
you stick with the European rules and
regulations but then you can't divert
your own ones or you negotiate ones
where you're more distant but that will
take much longer so the challenge will
be can he get it done in time and and he
said very clearly in the manifesto that
there would not be an extension of that
that said with this kind of authority
Boris Johnson can basically whip up that
commitment and and spend much more time
negotiating it if he wants to so it will
be a real question I think and we'll see
in the first few months of 2020
whether he wants to go to take longer to
negotiate a an agreement or whether he's
determined
to stick to his pledge of doing it
quickly in which case there is a risk
that there isn't actually an agreement
with the EU at the end of 2010 I agree
with all of that but the people had two
things one is that the the people
sitting on the other side of the table
from the Europeans I Boris and his team
and now in a much more powerful position
they were before they've got the mandate
of the electorate they've got a powerful
government machine behind them they've
got the issue of whether we will
actually leave sorted out so all the
time when the Europeans were negotiating
with us they had the conscious
understanding that's the people you know
the Teresa may was weak and then we
might they might actually not leave
that's all sorted out and there's the
question of the the sort of populist
wave going around the world which the
Europeans need to take into account and
there was a sort of feeling I think in
elite circles of that populist wave was
coming to an end and that Trump was on
his way out and that perhaps you know
that brexit was a complete and utter
mess and the fact that Boris has just
got this huge Democratic boost indicates
that that wave was still got a long way
to go and that Europeans need to take
that into consideration it would be an
interesting test of whether you're
whether Europe thinks that this is a
technocratic protection of its existing
absolutely sort of trade and market or
whether it thinks more strategically
because there is clearly no doubt now
that Britain is leaving you know I
lament that but it's there's clearly no
doubt where this country is going and if
the Europeans are thinking strategically
they should see a prime minister who has
as Adrian says a huge majority with whom
they are going to have to deal over the
next few years so to have a sort of
petty bureaucratic wrangling about the
intricacies of the trade deal is
probably not in Europe's long term
strategic interest I'm not as convinced
as Adrian that they'll rise to that I I
think it's still perfectly possible that
we have you know petty wrangling
throughout 2020 the Europeans are very
good at petty wrangling but on the other
hand they have just definitively lost
one of the those powerful members and
they've lost it because of a very
powerful sense in Britain of democratic
deficit that the European Union is not
practically accountable than that then
that trying to finagle that vote didn't
work I think they do need to think about
that they need to treat it as a
political problem as well as a technical
problem now we've got a couple of live
questions that have just come in my home
Maharaj wants to know what does this
result mean for the Irish border that is
an extremely good question and one of
the trade-offs that Boris Johnson made
when he struck the withdrawal deal with
the European Union was that he basically
agreed to an effective border within the
Irish Sea and he and Northern Ireland
will stay de jure part of the United
Kingdom but de facto part of the single
market so the you know the real question
will be as he negotiates a permanent
trade deal what does that look like and
does that if that division continues
with an effective border within the
Irish Sea personally I think that that
means the cause of you know a unified
Ireland becomes much more real in the
next few years and this is one of the
you know many things that I think we
will start thinking about as this you
know as the sort of dust settles and we
start thinking about the consequences of
Boris Johnson's enormous majority it was
an unbelievably powerful majority in
England the red wall has crumbled but if
you look at what happened in Scotland
salute voted overwhelmingly for the SNP
Ireland also didn't vote so and then in
London moved the Tories did not do
terribly well in London you have a very
English populist nationalist party and
so I think he could have problems with
it it's gonna be very hard to deny the
Scottish a second referendum when the
SNP has done this well you've got as I
say if if brexit is a harder brexit
you're gonna have very strong push for
united ireland over the next few years
so i think there are some some real
issues for the union that's massively so
this is a triumph of national populism
but is triumph of English national
populism and the Scottish vote the Scots
voted in a very different way the
remainders seem to have come out on top
in Northern Ireland so the United
Kingdom is beginning to spit up and say
Boris Johnson has a number of really
high priorities to deal with one is the
question of
bring something for the north and the
Midlands other than just brexit which is
you know making a real difference to
their difference their lives and that
means that a very different sort of
conservatism from the Thatcher
conservatives the letting the market
ripped it much more interventionist
perhaps more protectionist I'm not sure
but certainly more more more concerned
with the the functioning of industrial
Britain which mrs. Thatcher wasn't
really that interested in and also the
question of preserving the Union which I
think Boris is Boris Johnson is
generally concerned about and that means
that we have to be very careful about
hubris very careful about about
regarding this election victory as a
license for English nationalism to do
what it wants it's driven by English
nationalism but English nationalism
actually has to be modern moderated and
contained in order to keep the United
came together that's why this is I think
the but has the potential of being a
very strong and lasting realignment but
we're it's not at all clear yet whether
that will be borne through and and you
know Boris Johnson has huge challenges
on that I mean he has been the economy
that he'll have to manage with his
brexit he has the union that he has to
manage I just gonna have to find ways as
you say to deliver for these northerners
who have frankly lent him their vote
these are still I think regions of the
country which are culturally labor which
are not you know I don't think this is
in any sense yet a permanent shift this
is a frustration with Corbin and a
frustration with brexit not having done
but if got done but if they feel that
they've been let down that vote could
shift Freight absolutely what I would
answer that that this is something that
the Conservatives have been thinking
about for some time Boris Johnson has
one of the most powerful policy units in
place that the Conservative Party has
have since mrs. Thatcher and most of the
people in that policy units are thinking
very seriously about the issue of the
north and delivering for the north and
very thinking very seriously about their
sort of patriotic nationalism that
incorporates
Ireland and Scotland so he has a lot of
the materials and Dominic Cummings who
was the the architects of this whole
strategy you know he comes from from
Durham and his whole shtick has been
about taking note all northern
resentments and northern not northern
annoyances so I think just as misses you
know the Thatcherism was a sort of
rolling realignment that they sort of
constantly reinvented themselves and
constantly extended and deepened what
they were thinking about I think we're
going to see the same same with Boris
and some of the materials for that are
already there never underestimate the
capacity of the Conservative Party I'm
always struck by the contradictions
within this nation coalition but that
will whether they pull that off in the
next few years it's going to be the
single biggest question in British
politics really I'll take another
question from live viewers and tala r1
has asked specifically to Adrian I think
it's off the back of something he said
earlier what would be the impact of UK
election of the UK election results on
NATO
how will it shape UK US relations very
good question I mean I think the most
extraordinary thing about the selection
from NATO's point of views if we don't
have Jeremy Corbyn Jeremy called him was
the biggest single threat to NATO and to
the the broader Western alliance that
Britain was a part of since the Second
World War II know he's anti-nato he's
been anti West and that all of that's
been removed and one of the reasons he
lost was precisely because his foreign
policy was same dodgy so it's a sort of
vote for a very traditional foreign
policy and Morris will Morris Johnson
will will deliver a very conventional
thing in terms of our strategic
architecture on military architecture
when it comes to America that's even
more interesting because Morrissey was
in fact born in a hospital in New York
City and is you know instinctively very
pro-american has instinctively from the
wing of the Tory Party that's talked a
great deal about the Anglo sphere and
how Britain needs to be close to the to
the anglo-saxon anglocentric countries
and more distant from Europe he will he
will in some senses try and forge that
relationship with the United States with
Trump who gets on personally but also
with Australia which has been very
vigorous in pushing for a lot of
dyspraxia stuff with Canada New Zealand
to a lesser extent
and he will use that leverage in his
negotiations with the with the United
with the European Union say you say well
you know if you push us too hard will
just float off into the middle of the
Atlantic there will be an interesting
test of this though as he Boris Johnson
will no doubt want to start negotiating
a trade deal with the Americans very
quickly Donald Trump very keen to do the
same but the sort of brutal reality is
that two of the priorities of the United
States are greater access for us drugs
and higher prices and shorter patents
for us drugs in in return and access for
us agricultural products including the
infamous chlorinated chicken and both of
those are totemic issues in this country
in their particularly totemic issues in
in many of those northern seats that
have just been won by Boris Johnson the
NHS is absolutely the National Health
Service absolutely something that is
essential to these voters so I think
that's one example of the many areas
where Boris Johnson has got a very fine
you know balance to strike and a very
careful dance to play because on the one
hand he desperately needs and wants a
trade deal with the US but particularly
there's new constellation of voters that
he's got he can't be seem to sell out
the NHS so that's going to be very very
interesting to watch and they're
ruthless and relentless negotiators
trade negotiations the Americans they
know pretty good at making things you
know he's about America first absolutely
so we've touched on this already but
that's maybe want to take a closer look
at what the results mean for the future
of British politics here at the
Economist we've lamented the
polarization of British politics we've
talked a bit about the Conservatives
capture of the North pointing to a mass
political realignment and we've had a
live question in from beyond McDonald
who wants to know how will Boris Johnson
keep unity very very good question and I
think he has as Adrian has explained I
think rather compellingly the Tory Party
has a history of this and it has done it
in the past and it just remade itself in
order to sustain these new coalition's
but it is a very interesting coalition
this these these swathes of northern
working-class seats that the Tories have
now won in they are very very different
kinds of people than the wealthy you
know southern Tories and so you have
this coalition of you know blue collars
and red trousers which is a new
coalition it's one that you know lots of
people including I'm sure there will be
endless and very welcome badgered
columns about the we know what this
means but I think Boris Johnson has to
find ways to show to these new northern
voters who have lent him their vote that
he can deliver for them I actually think
some of it will be he is his personality
but some of it will be infrastructure
there's going to be Boris Johnson loves
building things he's a bit like Donald
Trump in that sense loves bridges loves
railways there's nothing like what they
want infrastructure and actually that's
really important and that is something
that could usefully there could be a
huge improvement infrastructure in the
north and so there are ways in which he
can do things that will be will sort of
show that stuff is happening but that's
gonna be a very big challenge can this
coalition be held together because he's
thus far being able to essentially hint
to the southern more Thatcherite
constituency that brexit means global
Britain more deregulation of freer
economy what these northern voters want
is not that at all it's something quite
different so he's going to have to
straddle water to at the moment very
very different cuz it's one thing we
haven't focused on in this discussion is
what's what's happening on the left with
Corbin I mean this is a extraordinary
humiliation for calming it's the worst
performance of the Labour Party since
the the 1995 an extraordinary bad
performance and yet Corbin last night
was system as was saying this in in it
is I thought rather petulant speech when
he won his constituency in North in
Islington North that he's going to stay
on in a while to preside over the
succession and I think the Labour Party
is gonna have a massive fight on its
hands about where it goes from here and
their two wings of the Labour Party one
is that the the Islington wing the
London wing which will say basically we
you know
quite well in the south we did very well
in London basically we need to be a
cosmopolitan party and the and the other
wing which is the northern working class
wing which will say we can't really
survive as a party without recapturing
there's northern working-class
territories and I think that what we
will tend to what the Labour Party will
tend to move towards is a party that
wants to recapture the north from from
Boris Johnson and it will do so by
continuing with us of a modulated
version of Corbin ISM by saying lots of
infrastructure trying to outbid the
Tories on on spending on hospitals on
infrastructure and things like that but
sort of rather dumping the the audit
parts of Corbin ISM which is a support
for Hamas and Hezbollah in the IRA
turning a blind eye to anti-semitism so
I suspect the person who will emerge
from this coming battle in the Labor
Party will be something like Angela
Raina who is northern working-class
traditionally traditionalists about
defense issues but also believes in a
very activist korbinites state but you
will have all these people in London who
will say actually we just need to be a
Blair I party but if you're if you're
right about that and that's what happens
with the Labour Party and it sticks with
essentially sort of you know reasonably
far left policies without the you know
without Corbett without urbanism without
Hezbollah without Corbin and the Tories
become this English nationalist sort of
socially conservative economically
interventionist party the real losers
then are the you know frankly people
like us the real losers are the you know
outward looking socially liberal
economically more free-market elements
which had been the elements that are
dominated the Tory Party until now and
which are essentially the elements of
Blair ISM and so that Center ground
which was you know where Cameron was
where Blair was has really worked it's I
wouldn't say it's gone too busy with as
you as you said it's not clear how Boris
Johnson is going to square this
constituency so it is possible that the
Tories I'll remain retain some of that
and certainly many of them
they would like to but it is it is also
possible that that Center ground has
gone and that there is no home no
natural and the one thing we haven't
talked about in this is the dystrophic
especially for the Liberal Democrats and
the Liberal Democrats their leader lost
her seat Joe Swinson in Scotland it was
it it was a pouring evening for them and
even though there are many people in
this country who who I think identify a
sort of centrist output looking socially
liberal people there is no party that
has successfully represented them and
that Center ground those Center parties
had a terrible night yes so if you're on
the right or the center of the Labour
Party and you say what we need to do is
go back to the Blair ID formula people
say well wait a minute look at the
Liberal Democrats that's that's not
where the votes are we don't need to
pile up more votes in Islington or
Battersea there wasted votes we need to
extend our reach back into our old half
man so that's why I think that the
Labour Party it will move to the right
in the sense of dumping some of the
absurdities of Corbin is Medivh won't
move to the right that much on its
economic policy be don't have and quite
the extravagant promises of the last
manifesto would be in the same area but
one thing another thing that we haven't
talked about which i think is who is
very interesting in terms of what Boris
Johnson has to offer people in the north
and Midlands and you know the broader
working-class if we talk a lot about the
difficulty of offering solving people's
economic problems but a lot of what
people worried about was it was cultural
anxiety it's a fact the sense that the
country is no longer the country that
they grew up in that immigration is too
high that social change is too high that
their fundamental rather traditionalist
conservative values are being
disrespected by islington with some of
its weirder weirder beliefs that's you
know that that basically the The
Cosmopolitan release is not patriotic
it doesn't share our values and what
Boris gonna do you know it sort of
Boyzone history of England you know when
a great country we've done all these
marvelous things you can do this
assertion of patriotic values
satisfy a lot of what the the the those
areas have been worried about you know a
lot of a lot of what the the Islington
wing of the Labour Party is about has
always been pointed essentially no point
to get these people in in in the rest of
the country and saying there's something
wrong with you there's something wrong
with your basic fundamental values your
instincts you're not up with things you
know and so he will really bang that
drum of cultural conservativism of a
country that we can feel comfortable
that everybody this is a man who has now
put his stamp on the Tory Party and he
may be able to pull this off but if he
doesn't we do risk having in this
country a sort of a far left party still
yes and a sort of frankly rather
unappealing culturally conservative
nationalist English party the way to
avoid that will be Boris Johnson really
doing what he says he is which is being
a one nation Tory and and pulling the
Tory party knotted sort of putting it
off those extremes of those those two
extremes to something that is a new and
a place where actually centrists can
feel at home to will see Boris Johnson
you know he you have to say hats off to
him he yes he is in many ways you know a
slippery individual he has a very very
you know loose relationship with the
truth he's he's used in this campaign
was full of all kinds of tactics you
know you wrote an excellent column that
this was the post truth election every
trick imported from the Trump campaign
and wherever it was not an edifying
election but now there is this really
quite striking result and so the
question isn't kind of what will the
real Boris Johnson be and will he turn
out to be you know the Chilean figure
he'd like to be its it bangs a lot hangs
on this man I think David Cameron called
him a greased pig lot and he does seem
to be incredibly good at reinventing
himself a bit changing but we do have to
give him a certain amount of credit and
I think a certain amount of iron has
entered his soul
I never ever venture to think though I
think he's a what he may not have a soul
but I invented something whatever he has
and that is that he's a he's a much
harder edged politician than he was
before
he's much more determined I mean he was
quite badly burned personally by by you
know the his unpopularity in supporting
leave you know in in in Islington
amongst his friends
I think that's chastened him but it's
also hardened him that we shouldn't
underestimate how hard a character he is
willing to do how much pain he's willing
to willing to take to deliver what he
what he wants and he grew up saying that
he wanted to became the world you know
he's king of a significant country and I
think he will want to go down in history
as a successful transformative
politician he's a very very ambitious
figure and whether he consider obviously
a lot depends on whether he can deliver
that but we shouldn't underestimate him
you know he did very he took a lot of
big Gamble's he probed Parliament
everybody said this was a crazy thing to
do he kicked out 20 more than 20 very
well-known MP's just deprived them the
whip ever thought he was going
completely crazy
he you know he basically dared the other
parties to give him an election they
gave him an election and he's won every
bet he's put on the table he's won the
Gamble has paid off so far away and we
have another live question from Jason
tap and who asks is this stronger
government what Britain needs to get out
of their slump I think having a strong
government has it definitely has its
advantages we now have a clarity and we
now have a govern that will get things
done I hope that there's also government
that will move things in the right
direction but yes I mean it is clearly
the the sort of British people have said
we've had enough of you know uncertainty
we've had enough of you know not knowing
where we're going with this breaks that
thing let's just go and you know we're
now going so to that degree it is a good
thing great and we published a film
yesterday which explored the recent
chaos in British politics you can watch
that by following the link in the
description and we are running short on
time now so we'll
as a final question will we look back on
this as a historic turning point in
British politics yes as important as the
election of mrs. Thatcher in 1979 and
you you know not least because it means
to finish them well we are leaving the
European Union but because it's creating
the political realignment which will
really matters not just in terms of who
sits where in Parliament but in terms of
what policies the the Conservative Party
and ultimately the Labour Party gonna be
delivering I think we will see it as a
turning point I think what's not yet
clear is where we will see it for a
turning point for you know for the
better or not and Britain has the chance
Britain has traditionally been a country
that has often been in the vanguard of
remaking the social contract it did it
in the early 20th century with the new
liberals with Lloyd George it did it
after 1945 with the you know beginning
the welfare state was invented here did
it with with Thatcher in 1979 it is
possible that this is one of those
moments that there is a new kind of you
know English nationalist conservative
but not too extreme remaking of the Tory
Party that we are seeing the beginnings
of but I am probably less confident than
Adrian about that I think it is a
turning point but I'm not at all clear
yet whether it's a turning point for the
dramatically better great well thank you
both I'm you thank you the first link in
the description will take you to the
economists ongoing coverage of the
election as events unfold and don't
forget to like and subscribe and thank
you very much for watching
you